even without Chadwick Boseman black
panther is ready to claw its way back to
the top of the box office here's
everything you should know before your
next trip to wakanda
obviously Marvel Studios had to
drastically change its plans for black
panther wakanda forever following
Chadwick boseman's death and it pushed
its original May 6 2022 release date to
July 8 2022. Angela Bassett Queen Ramona
herself told Entertainment Tonight that
there had been five drafts of the script
after his passing she explained I don't
know what it's going to look like at all
there have been about five incarnations
of the script and I hear another one's
coming of course with our dear King
Bozeman going on to Glory a lot of
things had to be shifted and changed
hopefully it will be satisfying I think
for fans and it will be honorable of our
Chad we love our King this all meant
that production had to be pushed back
until the summer of 2021 and it lasted
until March 2022. the film was pushed
again to November 11 2022 amongst
several other Marvel movies with variety
reporting that these delays were due to
production issues thankfully the film is
still on track to arrive in theaters
later this year the first black panther
wakanda forever teaser is an
enlightening look at the sequel without
actually giving too much away the
emotional footage is scored to Tim's
cover of Bob Marley's no Woman No Cry as
wakanda Mourns its Fallen King meanwhile
shuri Queen Ramona Nakia and Okoye all
grieve for their loved one wakanda is in
a very weak position so it isn't long
before Neymar shows up and starts
causing trouble for shuri and her family
unfortunately it isn't clear why this
war has erupted between wakanda and
talocan but it probably has something to
do with the talukan seeing the water is
their realm there are brief shots of
some kind of giant research ship
lowering two people in mechanical suits
into the ocean so perhaps they've
trespassed on the talukin's territory or
damage something which has enraged them
either way there are several glimpses of
Namor and the talocans Warren with the
Dora melange so let's hope for some
brilliant fights on land and at Sea it's
entirely possible that outside forces
are manipulating the two Nations but
there's nothing in the trailer to
suggest a secret big bad just yet even
if the internet thinks otherwise well
we'll get to that the most important
takeaway from the teaser is that it ends
with someone else wielding a brand new
black panther suit which is decked out
in Gold details this time around there
are plenty of candidates out there but
it looks like I might be sure getting
some new does do not tell me what is
possible tell me the truth one of the
biggest questions fans have about
wakanda forever revolves around the
identity of the next Black Panther after
all t'challa leaves some very big shoes
to fill as the nation's leader and a key
member of The Avengers the easiest
option is obviously shuri since she gets
her own black panther costume in the
comics and British star Leticia writes
is reprising her role as the King's
sister in the sequel there's been some
controversy surrounding right throughout
the pandemic and she previously
retweeted some supposedly
anti-vaccination opinions which was met
with heavy backlash from some fans The
Hollywood Reporter would later claim
that the actress was making her anti-vax
stance known while working on the Black
Panther sequel in Atlanta Wright later
refuted these reports on Instagram
saying I honestly assert that this was
completely untrue so it'll be
interesting to see whether she does get
her own suit bright previously told
black girl nerds that shuri throws
herself into her work as a way of
processing her grief or t'challa so
expect to see plenty of new technology
she explained so there's so much new
technology to look forward to and I
think that's where her sweet spot is at
the moment like how do I process this
and she just throws all of her energy
even more so in to technology so there's
a lot of cool new things to look out for
rumors swirled online that Mexicans
start to know chuerta would be joining
the film as Neymar the Submariner this
wasn't confirmed until San Diego
Comic-Con 2022 when Kevin feige brought
the star on stage during Marvel Studios
Hall age presentation Puerto was pretty
enthusiastic about joining the MCU
telling the audience I'm so happy to be
here it's an honor I want to say
something really fast about inclusion
thanks to inclusion I'm here I wouldn't
be here without inclusion and a lot of
kids are there looking at us grinning at
us because we're here by the way Namor
is amazing
a listing for Hasbro's name War figure
also revealed a surprising fact about
his home because while he's from
Atlantis in the comics Marvel Studios
has renamed the underwater Kingdom to
telecan This was later confirmed in a
press release about the Black Panther
wakanda forever prologue album from
Ludwig gorenson it's largely because
Marvel has worked in Mayan Aztec culture
into Neymar's people this can be seen in
his design which is complete with winged
ankles and green Trunks from the comics
Believe It or Not Neymar is actually
Marvel's very first mutant in the comics
chronologically speaking he's a
combination of Atlantean DNA and human
DNA which grants him the powers of the
talicans while also maintaining a
typically human appearance it's an
impressive mix of genes and aside from
breathing underwater Namor can also fly
which also leads back to his mutant
makeup the MCU is quickly racking up
many younger Heroes across Kevin feige's
Grand superhero tapestry and there's
another one on her way Riri Williams
played by Dominique Thorne Williams is a
genius inventor and a relatively new
character in the comics first arriving
in Invincible Iron Man vol 3 number 7.
she builds their own version of the Iron
Man armor and eventually suits up as a
wrong hero Iron Heart byge revealed that
ironheart is getting their own TV show
at the 2020 Disney investor Day
presentation which was incredibly
exciting news in itself sometimes you
gotta run before you can walk but it
wasn't until August 2021 that feige
revealed to comicbook.com that Thorne
will also have a supporting role in
wakanda forever saying we're shooting
black panther wakanda forever right now
and the character of Riri Williams you
will meet in Black Panther 2 first she
started shooting I think this week
before her ironheart series for the
moment it's not clear how williams gets
involved with wakandans mainly because
her comics origin starts when she's at
College at the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology
one of the most memorable supporting
characters in wakanda is a formidable
embaku played by Winston Duke the leader
of the Jabari tribe they're the most
traditional clan in the isolated Nation
because they've turned away from the
country's Reliance on vibranium and
advanced technology instead imbako and
his tribe live high up in the mountains
only descending to meet other groups for
occasions like t'challa's Ascension to
King where the leader challenged him for
the title of black panther he winds up
becoming one of t'challa's allies after
Michael B Jordan's killmonger usurps the
hero even saving him from certain death
after he was thrown from the top of a
cliff it seems like imbaku has brought
the Jabari into the 21st century as duke
previously told Screen Rant I think the
events of infinity war and end game
really showed that the Jabari are now
full-fledged members of wakanda imbaku
was a part of every single conflict
every event and I don't think they could
really exist in isolation anymore they
have opened borders and we saw that
mbaku was really wakandan his entire
Community has expanded it sounds like
he'll be at the Forefront of a lot of
action this time around as The Hollywood
Reporter previously revealed that Duke
has negotiated a bigger salary for an
expanded role in SQL 2018's black
panther was stacked with a truly
talented cast including British star
Daniel caluya who was previously
nominated for best actor at the Oscars
for his role in Jordan peele's get out
he won best supporting actor for Judas
in the black Messiah he's appeared in
Black Panther as t'challa's confidante
and best friend wakabi a member of the
Border tribe whose father was killed by
Andy circuses Ulysses claw years before
the events of the film this is part of
the reason that he sides with killmonger
when he delivers claw's body as a way of
getting into wakanda although okabe's
New Alliance forced him against his
friends and family he manages to stay
alive by the end of the film however
wakabi won't show up in wakanda forever
because kaluya was already set to work
on Peel's science fiction horror flick
no according to Rotten Tomatoes
Jacqueline Coley the schedules for both
films clashed at the time it's not
surprising that kaluya opted to stay on
board for no since he did some of his
best work with peel and get out
mm-hmm Marvel Studios has a great knack
for attracting Hollywood Legends
alongside up-and-coming talent but black
panther wakanda forever is a stacked
cast full of huge names with years of
experience behind them Angela Bassett is
back as Queen Ramona while The Walking
Dead Alum deny Guerrero will Don her
Dora Malaysia uniform again is Okoye
she'll be joined by Florence kasumba's
Ayo who was last seen in the Falcon in
the Winter Soldier I may destroy you
lead actress Michaela Cole is joining
the MCU as Anika who is a former member
of the Dora Malaysia in the comics
likewise Martin Freeman is back a CIA
agent Everett Ross meanwhile down in
talikan tanachuerta's underwater forces
are bolstered by Mabel kadinas nemoura
and Alex leave and Ali's atuma the late
Dorothy Steele has also reprized the
role as the merchant tribe leader in one
of her final performances before her
death on October 2021 at the age of 95.
Ryan coogler is back on directing duties
for wakanda forever it's a complete
no-brainer for Marvel Studios
considering the first film earned over 1
billion dollars worldwide and was a
critical hit as well as a commercial one
thankfully The Man Behind Fruitville
Station and Creed isn't short of ideas
for the MCU and it clearly works well
within the system alongside the likes of
Kevin feige and Victoria Alonso as per
for Forbes the director signed on for
the sequel back in 2018. not long after
the first film raked in all that profit
he's done a very difficult job of
steering the ship after Chadwick
boseman's untimely passing and it's not
something he's taken lightly while
speaking to The Hollywood Reporter
coogler explained that he feels the star
would want him to carry on he said it's
difficult you've got to keep going when
you lose loved ones I know Chad wouldn't
have wanted us to stop he was somebody
who was so about the collective so it
would be harder for me to stop
truthfully I'd feel him yelling at me
like what are you doing so you keep
going
you've been one thankfully the first
teaser suggests that coogler has once
again held an adventure that could be
truly special let's face it the MCU
timeline is a sprawling tapestry that is
very hard to keep track of this is
especially true when you consider all
the time travel Shenanigans at the
Avengers and Loki get up to in the
movies and shows on Disney plus all of
that is only going to get more
complicated as the studio jumps head
first into the Multiverse with future
projects like Loki season 2 Avengers the
Kang Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
thankfully black panther wakanda forever
seems to be more of a grounded movie
rather than involving Cosmic Concepts
and Alternate realities because it's
also the final film of phase four it
seems likely that it's set in the
present day of the MCU after the likes
of Ms Marvel Thor 11 Thunder and
She-Hulk although considering it's
introducing Neymar to the big screen for
the very first time we can probably
expect to see some flashbacks to his
origin and how talikan became the sunken
city that it is now this isn't to say
that it won't lead up to bigger plot
points in movies but it seems like a
safe bet that it'll be focused on the
here and now because it'll honor the
legacy of both Chadwick Bozeman and
t'challa okay let's address the Doctor
Doom in the room with movies like
Fantastic Four and Avengers Secret Wars
on the horizon it doesn't seem long
until we can predict when and where
legendary villain Dr Doom finally
returns to the big screen but there are
a few rumors online suggesting that a
new version of the lapirian bad guy is
on the way it makes sense if Marvel
Studios borrows from Jonathan Hickman's
2015 event series Secret Wars one
persistent rumor says that Dr Doom will
be revealed in some capacity toward the
end of black panther will come to
Forever a report from bleeding cool
claims that Doom puppeteers the war
between wakanda and talocan for his own
ends although it's not clear why the
site noted that while Doom's apparent
role won't be big it will imply that
this wakanda Atlantis war was a result
of Doom's interference interesting he's
one of many villains who's trying to
overthrow wakanda for many years so it
would hardly be surprising if he's just
looking to get his metal gauntlets on
all that vibranium it would be easy to
imagine Doom taking his rightful place
in the MCU but to introduce him solely
is an overarching character could be
disappointed is going to start showing
up more frequently over the next few
years we'll just have to endure the pain
of waiting and see whether Dr Doom is
coming painful
you don't know the meaning of the word
when it comes to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe one can always expect a cameo
or two bridging heroes from one film to
another is the backbone of how this
comic book inspired Universe handles
itself however with the roster of the
MCU franchise constantly expanding it
has become more difficult to guess which
characters might appear in which movies
aside from the confirmed cast list there
are some knowledgeable guesses as to who
may pop up in Black Panther wakanda
forever as confirmed at San Diego Comic
Con 2022 black panther wakanda forever
will be the official end of Marvel's
fourth phase the exception of course as
James Gunn stated on Twitter is that of
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special which will serve as an epilogue
looking back at Marvel's latest stories
one character has helped to thread the
phase together a sorcerer's Supreme Wong
he snug his way into multiple phase 4
outings including chongqi and the legend
of the ten Rings Spider-Man no way home
and She-Hulk it would not be unexpected
to see the master sorcerer make another
appearance meanwhile another name that
has been closely linked to Black Panther
2 is the mcu's newest Captain America
Anthony Mackey despite the actor stating
that he is not film he did confirm that
he visited the set via the Twitter
account black panther news this led to
speculation that this may be the first
time audience to see Mackie in his new
uniform since Falcon and the Winter
Soldier of course the tragic fact is
that the upcoming black panther sequel
is missing its star Chadwick Boseman the
character t'challa quickly became a fan
favorite with his debut in Captain
America Civil War aside from headlining
his own feature in 2018 Bozeman
continued his reign as the king of
wakanda throughout two Avengers movies
sadly at 43 years old Bozeman died of
colon cancer in August 2020 losing such
an integral piece of the franchise was
undoubtedly difficult for the cast and
crew and moving forward with a sequel
however Chadwick boseman's brother Derek
Boseman confirmed to TMZ that the late
actor would have wanted the legacy of
black panther to continue though talks
about recasting briefly swirled they
were put to rest by Marvel Studios
president Kevin feige who confirmed that
bringing in a new face to play t'challa
was never an option further feige told
deadline in 2021 that the actor would
not be inserted into the movie through
CGI most fans can agree that Marvel made
the right decision in proceeding with
the sequel that honors Bozeman rather
than replacing or simulating him and
that doesn't change the fact that for
the cast and crew there's a notable
absence Martin Freeman who will reprise
his role as cih and Everett Ross told
collider at the heart of it there's
quite a gap now when you felt it based
on Freeman's remarks audiences can
expect Bozeman's presence to be felt
throughout the film especially as the
plot centers around his character's
Legacy with the premier black panther
wakanda Forever fast approaching fans
began receiving their first Clues to the
plots and premise of the sequel in 2022
the official synopsis released by Marvel
Studios reads Queen Ramona shuri and
Baku Okoye and Adora milaje find to
protect their Nation from intervening
world powers in the wake of King
t'challa's death as wakandans strive to
embrace their next chapter the heroes
must band together with the help of War
Dog Nakia and Everett Ross and Forge A
New Path for the kingdom of wakanda at
the conclusion of the first Black
Panther movie The King of wakanda chose
to reveal the secret Nation to the world
and share their advancements with the
rest of society we must find a way
look after one another the aftermath and
Revelations of this reveal will
significantly impact the sequel's plot
especially as the nation of wakanda is
left leaderless it's also easy to Guess
that a new black panther will be crowned
during the events of wakanda forever
[Music]